نعود مره اخرى الى الخرطوم همم في متابعه
ايضا لمراسم توقيع على اتفاق الايطالي في
القصر الجمهوري بالعاصمه الخرطوم ونتابع
معكم هذه اللقطات المباشره الان من مقر
همم ايضا المقر الذي سيتم من خلاله توقيع
هذا الاتفاق الايطالي في السودان بين
القوى السياسيه همم
حسب من بعض ما كشفت منه عنه بعض القوى
يتضمن هذا الاتفاق بنودا مختلفه من اهمها
تسليم السلطه
الانتقاليه الى سلطه مدنيه كامله
وتتكون ايضا من من مستوى السيادي مدني
بمهام شرفيه ايضا ينتظر ان توقع عدد من
القوى السياسيه والحركات المسلحه الاتفاق
مع المكون العسكري سوف يشمل التوقيع الجيش
السوداني وقوه الحريه والتغيير المجلس
المركزي وقوى الانتقال الديمقراطي وحركات
الكفاح المسلح ومن المقرر ان توقع الاحزاب
المنضويه تحت التحالف المجلس المركزي على
الاتفاق الاداري ما عدا حزب البعث العربي
الاشتراكي بالاضافه الى الحركات
المنضويه تحت ااه تحالف الجبهه الثوريه ما
عدا حركتين العدل والمساواه بقياده جبريل
ابراهيم وجيش تحرير السودان بقياده بني
اركوناوي ايضا ستوقع التيارات داخل
الاتحاد الديمقرا الاصل والمؤتمر الشعبي
وجماعه صار السنه المحمديه على اتفاق في
المقابل هناك بعض القوه التي ترفض هذا
الاتفاق مثل الحريه والتغيير الكتله
الديمقراطيه
ومبادره نداء اهل السودان وقوه التغيير
الجذري بالاضافه الى عدد من لجان المقاومه
كل هذه الاطراف ترفض هذا الاتفاق الايطالي
هذه القوه
ورفضها لهذا الاتفاق دفعها كما يعني تشير
بعض الانباء للدعوه الى التسعيد على سبيل
المثال الكتله الديمقراطيه
ومبادره نداء اهل السودان دعت في بيانين
منفصلين لتصعيد السلمي لمناهضه الاتفاق
ايضا حاولت عدد من اللجان المقاومه في
العاصمه الخرطوم تظاهرات كان من المقرر ان
تكون او وجهتها غير مركزيه الى مركزيه همم
نحو تصل الرئاسي صباح اليوم
التزامنا مع مراسم التوقيع على الاتفاق
الايطالي واطلقت لجان مقاومه همم المقاومه
لمدينه الخرطوم موكب اسقاط ورفض التسويه
على تظاهرات اليوم همم من جانبها السلطات
في ولايه الخرطوم كذلك استقبلت تظاهرات
اليوم باغلاق جسر الملك النمر الرابط بين
مدينتي الخرطوم بحري كنا في متابعه ايضا
مع مراسله مراسلاتنا التي تتواجد في مقر
انعقاد هذا الاجتماع التي تتحدث عن مراسم
همم هذا التوقيع التي تتضمن مجموعه من
الكلمات